i feel like i say it again and again and
again and again hey everyone i'm abby
sharp welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by billbar
and we'll be revisiting fitness
influencer daisy keach but first let me
tell you about my sponsor billboard it
is snack time o'clock in my house and i
am treads excited for my non
francophones tres means
very in french i know super
sophisticated but i am tres excited
today because it is a built bar puff day
and these things give me life
i don't even know where we're gonna go
where are we gonna go
churro banana cream pie
oh what
coconut marshmallow hello you guys know
i love me a good coconut chocolate combo
[Music]
she good these taste like the chocolate
covered marshmallows that i used to get
for like easter
in my chocolate hunt
but with protein
adult easter hunt and if you really want
to make your day you like pair this with
some oatmeal or fruit and you will love
your life
i mean this has 17 grams of protein
amazing so if you want to try these out
yourself check out my link in the
description and use my promo code
abbiesharp15 to get 15 off of your order
and you can pause the screen or look at
my description to check out my
disclaimer including a trigger warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating so as
always feel free to skip this video if
it's not supportive to your journey and
if you are not already subscribed hit
that subscribe button and follow me on
tick tock and instagram at abby's
kitchen so if you missed my previous
review of daisy you can check that out
right here but today you'll be taking a
look at what she eats in a day to build
her booty so without further ado let's
jump in at first i kind of like eating
sourdough didn't really feel right to me
but then i'm like well if i'm going to
work out
these carbs are going to go to my
workout it's going to go to fuel
my body so i have energy so i don't
think it's that bad and plus i like it
it's enjoyable for me here turkey bacon
um this is my favorite one it's just
from whole foods all together
i couldn't help but take a bite of my
avocado toast so basically same same as
last time but with a little more carbs
from the fruit which i am relieved to
see since my feedback from the previous
review was to add more morning carbs to
help fuel her workout so this time we've
got carbs in the fruit plus bread
healthy fats from the avocado and a
little protein in the bacon and a little
in the sourdough as well obviously i'm
relieved she's open to eating like a
slice of bread but i'm not into the
message that carbs are not that bad or
okay because they are going towards her
workout folks food never needs to be
earned in exercise even if you've just
been like laying in bed watching my
videos all day
and sourdough bread specifically is such
a nutritious powerhouse since the
fermentation process reduces the
anti-nutrient content by 24 to 50
percent so nutrients become even easier
to absorb and if she likes it which she
says she does it needs zero
justification for its consumption i also
want to reiterate the comment i
previously made about her uncured turkey
bacon since i guess this is still a
staple in her diet even though the label
says nitrate free it still technically
contains nitrates via natural curing
agents like celery powder and the
verdict is still out on whether or not
natural versus synthetic nitrates have a
different effect on the body most
experts suspect that it's virtually the
same but what we do know is that we
don't have as strict limits on maximums
or caps on natural nitrates like we do
for synthetic ones so it is actually
possible that you could get more
nitrates from nitrate-free products than
the og so my hot take here is to enjoy
sources of nitrates in ultra processed
foods like bacon in moderation
regardless of whether they're made with
synthetic or natural nitrates even
healthy foods can become unhealthy in
excess focusing on diet variety is the
easiest most sure-fire way to ensure
that you're meeting your nutrient needs
and not inadvertently overdoing it on a
food component that in excess could
potentially cause harm like this
layered lards layered
vanilla superfood creamer so you guys
know i don't usually comment on coffee
you drink it how you like it but i was
intrigued by the claims of this creamer
so this layered brand almond milk
contains chaga mushroom extract and
lion's mane extract which likely
accounts for its superfood marketing
lion spain and chaga mushrooms are
loaded with antioxidants and some
research has shown that they may have
some anti-inflammatory benefits there's
also research suggesting that lion's
mane specifically may also have some
brain boosting benefits by kind of
helping protect against anxiety
depression and alzheimer's however the
majority of the research we have on
these mushroom extracts have only been
done on rats and also in much higher
quantities than would ever be present in
like a splash of creamer especially
since surprise surprise they don't even
list how much you actually get all we
know is that they're one of the last
ingredients on the list which means
they're present in the smallest amounts
by weight a mushroom could technically
fart on this almond milk and we could
call it a superfood and that's probably
all you'd wanted to do if you're not a
fan of like mushroom scented coffee but
bottom line we definitely need more
human research to get a better
understanding of these health benefits
and the clinically effective dose so
while technically you may be getting a
little antioxidant action in this
product you're probably getting a much
greater antioxidant boost from the
coffee itself
so it's actually the next morning now
let me just explain myself a little bit
um
yesterday i ended up having some
last-minute meetings for this brand that
i'm starting so
work comes first um i needed to get all
that done so i didn't have time to
work out but right now i only have an
hour
before i need to start working out so
i'm just doing some quick carbs right
here this is mush honey nut oats i maybe
eat this like one times a one time a
week
or if i just i need to work out so
because daisy only has like an hour
before her workout a smaller size meal
or snack is ideal to prevent her from
feeling uncomfortable or having
indigestion during her workout but still
giving her a little bit of fuel so a
little oatmeal bowl is a great option
but depending on the intensity a lot of
folks might need a little bit more most
sports nutrition experts will suggest
about one to four grams of carbs per
kilo of body weight for an optimal
pre-workout meal so for someone like
daisy this carb range would likely be
around 58 to 232 grams of carbs with
more intense and lengthy training
sessions requiring carbs on the upper
end of this range but seeing as daisy is
doing a less intense strength session
something around the 60 grand mark would
likely suffice and this could easily be
met by adding some banana raisins or
berries on top of her oats i mean it
really doesn't need to be complicated
and yeah i think it's really important
to get your carbs in before your workout
and then right after you work out so
that's usually what i do
i'll only have like two meals that have
carbs in it
during the day and then my other meal
won't usually have a carb in it
sometimes it will just depends how i'm
feeling because the most important thing
is really just to listen to your body i
feel like i'm lacking energy and i feel
like i need that
um carb then i'll add it to my third
meal and i've noticed that really helps
with just keeping myself lean but also
having the ability to grow up muscle
because it's a very tricky game when it
comes to staying lean and growing muscle
at the same time lots to unpack here yes
100 agreed we definitely want to get our
carbs in both before and after a workout
so the carbs will help to supply the
quick energy before the workout and
they'll help with muscle and glycogen
store recovery afterwards however what i
seem to be hearing implicitly or
explicitly a lot is that you only need
carbs if you're intentionally working
out and that is just not true none of
the information is correct even if we're
like laying horizontal watching netflix
all day our body still needs energy from
carbs to think breathe digest food move
support metabolism etc in fact assuming
you're not in a state of ketosis our
nutrition guidelines recommend about 45
to 65 of our total daily calories from
carbs so for someone around daisy's size
that's well over 200 grams now i don't
disagree that there's value in front
loading your carbs around your workout
and earlier on in the day since insulin
sensitivity tends to decline throughout
the day and it's at its peak in the
morning that doesn't mean our bodies
just like stop processing carbs after a
certain hour and we need to go like
full-on carnivore after four
there's a hot spinning cone of meat in
that greek restaurant next door i don't
know what it is but i'd like to eat the
whole thing ultimately everyone has to
find what feels best for them and if
daisy genuinely feels best going to bed
without carbs then great if it works for
her it works for me however i would just
be worried about an intention behind
restricting carbs being more about
helping one lean out to meet body goals
rather than actually listening to body
cues and desires because as we saw with
the sourdough bread it's clear that
daisy does enjoy carb containing foods
but it seems like she has to have a
performance-based justification to be
able to eat them so if she needs a
justification for carbs within the
context of body recomp or growing a
booty consider what my colleague sports
dietitian chelsea cross said to me when
i asked carbs fuel training which means
greater intensity in the gym which
allows you to better hit that stimulus
threshold to see muscle change also
consider your sleep sleep is one of the
most important factors in fat loss and
muscle growth and we know that having
carbs before bed can also help to
support a good sleep and very quick this
is because carbs may boost tryptophan
and serotonin in the brain which are
both involved in sleep so while i'm
fully supportive of working towards
meeting one's aesthetic body goals
drastically cutting carbs or calories in
order to reach them will actually just
delay their realization in between then
between working on a photo shoot i had a
protein shake and i'm having a lunch
i got
some chicken
salad
and then buffalo cauliflower vegan
and i'm not vegan by the way because
there's literally chicken on my plate
but i try to stay away from dairy
then
we got some rice
which i also probably didn't need
because i already have the cauliflower
so that's my carb
i did do booty day and i did do really
good on my hip thrust so
i kind of deserve it oh wow one
cauliflower has like six grams of carbs
per cup so even with a bit of breading
on it i wouldn't call that a high carb
side two even if her hip thrusts weren't
fire she absolutely should enjoy the
rice if she wanted it and since she did
say she was prioritizing her carbs
before and after workouts the 53 grams
of carbs per cup of rice would
definitely help to support post-workout
recovery so i do hope she actually
allowed herself to eat it she also
didn't mention what was in her protein
shake but in my last review it was just
spinach almond butter almond milk
protein powder and half of a banana so
if she didn't have the rice i would at
least hope for some carbs in the shake
and yes you can eat the whole damn piece
of fruit regardless of what she
eventually eats i think the ongoing
theme here from her language around food
is that carbs are to be restricted to
earned opportunities basically following
a hard sweat sesh in the gym and knowing
how high her carp needs likely are for
her activity level i do worry she may be
selling her body short
a little airbone gluten-free vegan
cookie
i got this yummy juice
it's called high vibe would like that
razor frequency granny smith oh my god
i'm dead okay
organic granny smith apple
organic pineapple organic rose water
organic lemon and organic beet organic
organic organic
okay here we are here
are the carbs
yes
your girl can chill out now we good hey
if you'd rather get your carbs from
cookies and juice rather than like
savory rice all good you do you i just
think it's interesting that she
demonized the rice which has like 53
grams of carbs but we didn't hear that
kind of shade about the health washed
vegan gluten-free and organic carbs from
the bougie la grocer even though
together they probably had a lot more
sugar and carbs psa organic cookies and
cold pressed juice are carbs not unlike
rice but they're just kind of packaged
up with a better pr team honestly i'm
just relieved we got carbs without any
commentary but i just wanted to point
out the irony of which types of foods
get shamed i've been a little bit of a
spoiled brat with my water
and i've only been drinking alkaline
water like when i have the option
obviously like when you go to grocery
store by alkaline water
um
because it's just better for your body
and it's better to keep your body at a
higher level of alkalinity if that makes
sense because
it just helps fight off diseases and
viral infections um
there's just been a lot of stuff not
like studies but kind of studies uh like
there's been a lot of people that have
tested it
on other people and that like had some
sort of
disease or some sort of chronic
something
and it's helped them oh gosh
not the alkaline water like have we not
done this to death okay very fast can
what you eat or drink change the ph of
your body no it cannot period our body
ph is very tightly regulated in fact you
wouldn't want your body to be more
alkaline because you actually probably
would die so what does alkaline water do
exactly well one small lab study
suggested that alkaline water might help
prevent acid reflux by deactivating the
stomach enzyme pepsin but on the other
hand though if you're not actively
struggling with acid reflux too much
alkaline water might lower stomach
acidity which is also not ideal either
as stomach acid is important for
digestion and eliminating bacteria as
for daisy's claim about kind of studies
showing that alkaline water helps to
fight off diseases and viral infections
kinda was the first red flag but yeah i
call pseudoscience on this one we really
don't have any legitimate evidence to
support these claims at all the most
that alkaline water can really do is
potentially make your urine more
alkaline and we actually wouldn't really
want that either as our urinary tract
prefers an acidic environment so when
things teeter over into like the more
alkaline territory it can allow bacteria
to thrive which increases the risk of
bacterial infections like utis so
overdoing it on the alkaline water is
essentially just creating more expensive
and potentially painfully infected pee
damn okay but is water in general good
for the body yeah 100 does water intake
fight off diseases and viral infections
well i mean a hydrated body technically
supports immunity by helping to
eliminate bacteria and toxins from the
body but it's certainly not a quick fix
for disease prevention or management
they're gonna hate me but i forgot to
film my dinner last night we made
chicken rice we literally just did like
the easiest dinner ever because we were
both tired and didn't feel like making a
whole last meal
and then we just did microwavable rice
which usually i don't like to do that
but you know how it is when you're just
tired in this salad
we get this salad mix from whole foods
it's called sweet kale mix or something
like that
um and it's my favorite it's so good and
i'll do like a honey ginger vinaigrette
and i'll add some raisins and some
cashews to it i love a good quickie meal
like this you got your veg and your
fiber from the salad kit with some
cashews on top for healthy fats you got
your carbs from the microwavable rice
and some protein from the chicken and if
you just can't be bothered to like thaw
and cook your chicken you could even
pick up a rotisserie chicken and call it
a day this sounds awesome and i love
that despite all the carb hate all day
the girl ate some carbs so
we love a happy ending with food so
before i give you my summarizing
thoughts i want to address the title of
this video and whether or not what you
eat can directly result in a booty the
short answer is obviously
no growing the glute muscles aka the
booty requires eating enough to fuel
muscle growth which requires a stimulus
threshold to be met eating enough is
arguably more important than the
specifics of what but the training and
let's be honest genetics is also key as
for this week of eating it's a bit
challenging to get an accurate picture
of daisy's daily intake as this video
was less of a what item a day and more
like random meals that i had this week
both on and off camera but overall i
would say the meals that we did see were
generally more or less balanced and
calorically adequate compared to my
previous review as we did have you know
some breakfast lunch dinner and some
snacks in between i was also pleasantly
surprised that despite all the carb
shaming she actually served a decent
amount of carbs in her meals which will
better support her energy needs and
recovery so i think we're definitely on
the right track on that front what i do
think is a problem is the moralizing
language around carbs and the hesitancy
to eat them if they're not explicitly
earned through activity i can sense and
appreciate the discomfort here for
anyone including daisy i mean i know
that these thought processes and die
behaviors can take a lot of time to
unlearn but i was still proud to see her
working through that by adding those
carbs in wherever she could progress is
progress and unlearning fitness and diet
culture is often a lifelong journey so
we love to see others challenging their
long-standing beliefs and on that note
that's all that i have for you guys
today a big thank you again to billbar
for sponsoring if you liked it be sure
to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below on who i should review
next subscribe to the channel and i'll
see you next time on abby's kitchen bye
[Music]